my name is Annika okay I'm nek
Henrickson and I've been living here in
nuke since I was a kid so it's about 33
years I've been living in nuke there's
been a lot of changes especially with
the city the city is growing very fast
for instance the area that we see behind
us it's an area my siblings there are
about 15 years older than me and they
used to go to this area when their kids
with our grandparents making a little
fireplace preparing the food they
weren't very picking and for myself I
used to go out here and my snowmobile
just to relax and enjoy the peace around
me and the nature and and now you can
see there's a an entire small city out
here it has yeah it's only for the past
eight years all this building has come
up so the city is developing very fast
but also the culture here in Greenland
it's it's obvious that it's getting much
more international and also with all the
facilities we have in the city and it's
all getting more international I mean we
have quite a lot of cafes and
restaurants and so on when I was a kid
we had absolutely no cafes and we had
one restaurant so it was quite limited
what do young people your reign to think
about all these changes I think that
most of the young people they really
like the development but still we are
quite concerned about our culture to
keep our culture and I mean our culture
has been in fluent it a lot by the
Danish culture so we grew up with
somehow protecting our culture and now
all of a lot of other people foreigners
are coming from other cities with the
oil and everything so a lot of we expect
a lot of Chinese people and American
people coming here that's that's really
exciting or everything foreign it's
always exciting I think but but it's
just important to keep your own history
in your own culture
not much actually I don't know much
about Newfoundland but one of my friends
went to Newfoundland to to study so a
Greenlandic girl like she liked it a lot
she she were supposed to stay there for
six months and she went back home after
four years so she really liked it what
are young people in Greenland think
about the oil industry should all be
pumped out of these waters hmm i think
that people are are split within that
matter in a way they like the
opportunity to to get a bit more wealthy
and get independent from Denmark but
we're still very concerned about the
nature cuz the nature has always been
the most important for us and we're very
worried that it will have an effect on
all the animals and the nature
surrounding us willing to take that risk
I haven't figured it out for myself to
be honest I'm not sure of course it's
it's nice with the money but money is
not everything I think that the nature
it's it's much more important you had
the nature for a really long time and
you have to survive this she's not very
thrilled about it as she's saying she
has been living here for almost 70 years
and she had had a happy life even that
they didn't have as much as we have now
but the most important part is that you
are heavy as a person and money can
change that and in basic oil is just
money right you're welcome